He laughs.
I am an idiot!
So, uh...I thought this game couldn't get any funnier, and, um, uhh....
He laughs once more.
Someone told me to turn on the Bobblehead option, so, um...
I'm gonna let him go. I'm just gonna let him go do his thing.
Oh, he's not gonna go anywhere! You son of a b****.
You handsome son of a b****, you!
This is absolutely ridiculous.
Where are you even going?
What is the point of this?
Where did my head go?!
What happened to me?!
Insert The Room reference here.
He laughs again.
Hiiiii~!
Let us try an slightly different path, you handsome devil.
WEEE!
You didn't hit anything!
You moron!
Oh, you look very happy about that situation there, buddy!
Alright! Take...wow. Really? Are you kidding me?
Aww, how could I be mad at you?
Stop giving me that look!
OKAY!
He laughs once more.
What the hell happened?!
What hap--Oh, there I am!
Hi, buddy! How you doing?
You don't feel so good, do ya?
Laughter.
I really can't handle this!
He couldn't talk over his laughter.
God!
This is so ri-god d***-diculous.
WEEEEEEEEEEE!!
Where did I go? What happened to me?
All I see are flying cars!
It's coming, I swear.
Laughter.
Why is it so funny to see my face being tossed around like that?
He laughs once again.
Hi, buddy! How are you?
All right. Oh, you came back...Oh, God!
What happened to you?! Tell me, who hurt you like this?!
WHO DID THIS TO YOU?!!
Oh, this won't end well....
Laughter.
What is happening to that?! Euhuhugh! Stop!
I feel more personal connection now!
It's okay, buddy, I'll meet you at the---
He laughs once more.
Oh, hello there. Nice--
Oh, is that your foot there or are you happy to see me?
Hello, there, baby!
He laughs again.
Did something happen to you? Oh, you just so sexy right now...
Hey, there, friend! How's it going? You look a little worried.
Le laugh!
Oh, no. He's fine!
Why ain't ya going up--There's the happiness!
There he is!
I'm like--He's like; You like what you see, baby?
That's why I go the fly! (or something)
Wait, OH, NO! There was more! I'm sorry! I'M SO SORRY--!
Oh, you're okay...It's gonna be all right! Look at that smile!
Did anyone ever doubt that smile?
Someone get help.
Markiplier has been officially broken.
Seriously, call the hospital.
I can't deal with this...I can't deal with it!
Nooooooo!
Weeeeeeeee!
Oh, good for you! YAAAY!
He can't handle such comedy.
This is by far - by far - the silliest thing I have ever done in my life.
This...is ri-god-d***-diculous, but it is so amazing!
I love it so much!
Am-Am I gonna be okay, doctor?!
This level is literally called "Wall of Train".
I dunno what I expected. Honestly.
Oh, God!
There goes my head!
Where, oh, where...could my face have gone?
I didn't see--Oh! Oh, is that it? Oh, is that it?!
Markiplier has stopped working again.
Hey, buddy! You look good!
Aw, yeah, my guy's ready to go!
My guy's ready to GO!
Where did my guy go?
Wha--?! What happened?!
What happened?!
Buddy! Are you okay?!
All right, now don't do whatever the hell happened before again.
WEEEE!
Okay--!! Where did my face go---No, no, no!!
Little buddy!! Little buddy!
Laughter.
I found him! I don't know where he's going but I found him!
Come on, baby! You can make it!
Okay, maybe not--
Greatest distraction ever.
OH, GOD, YOU D***!
You can make it!
Okay, maybe not.
AAAAAAAAAH---Le laugh again!
You ready for the ride of your life, buddy?
Where'd you go?
I wonder what will happen now.
Laughter.
But he still looks happy! And slightly confused.
Let's see what you can do! Oh, you missed the train!
You didn't miss that! Le laugh. Again. Okay...
Yippee! All riiiiiggghhht---
Oh, nohohohohoho!
Reminds me of me when I was an kid.
I used to get stuck in those things all the time! Oh, me...
Mmm, not very wrong--
Laughter.
I think you just severed your crotch.
Ready for a fun ride?! Oh, my God...!
Oh, you almost had that! Oh, what is going on with your arms?!
Looking good, buddy. Oh, looking good! You're gonna make it!
YEAH!
Uh...Uh, dude?! You left your a** twitching in that bird!
This is more my speed and style.
Oh, ye---Laughter.
Come on, little buddy! Make it all the way! That is--
Oh. He laughs. Hi! He laughs more.
Wait a minute, wait a minute, wait a minute...HIIIIII!
I swear, the stupidest things make me laugh, no matter what.
The stupidest s***.
But, god d*** it, I love it. God, this is flipping hilarious!
YEEEEEEEEE---
Where did I go? God...
And I'm still happy! All right!
All right, guys, that was more Turbo Dismount.
With my face, and holy crap, that was absolutely amazing.
I don't know why I found it so funny,
but if you guys enjoyed it and you want to see more Turbo Dismount,
especially if you wanna see it with my face on there--Hello, there!
Let me know about it by leaving an Like down below.
Thank you all so much for watching, and as always...
I will see you...in the next video.
Bye-bye!
Captions by ImSpidey2.